so DC is retelling the origin of the
Joker and the ending to this particular
comic is insane even though this is a
multi-part series it's crazy so what
this does is this really just picks up
with the joker running up a woman named
Sally coming out of her house right and
he says I know how I look but you've got
to believe me it's all because I love
you I got caught up in some really
terrible things so I could give you the
life you deserve I can fix this just
wait for me Sally wait for me and then
just storms off only for This Woman's
husband to come out and when he refers
to her as jod she's like I have no idea
who this person is now and so what this
does is it picks up 6 months after the
encounter and what you get is this kind
of almost inner monologue where it sort
of goes back and forth the reason for
this is because you have the Joker who's
putting on a kind of face paint to make
himself look normal right to look like a
regular human being to cover up his
bleach skin but as he's talking with
himself he talks about how he was
betrayed that somebody in the gang had
talked to the cops to Batman whoever and
you end up realizing he's looking at
himself in the mirror but he's seeing
the Red Hood now that's our first clue
as to when this comic takes place
because don't worry not going to leave
you hanging I'm going to make it all
make sense so at that point you pick up
with Commissioner Gordon now Gordon is
actually not a commissioner yet he's
really more of a detective at the moment
you've basically got uh commissioner m
who's the one sort of running the show
here and what's really big is that they
are on the hunt for Batman which is our
second clue as to when this takes place
and there's a little bit of back and
forth between the commissioner and
really Gordon himself and the sense that
he's being chastised right you're
extremely late report on the ace
chemical mess it's basically a love
letter to a vigilante and that's what
we're basically informed this takes
place almost immediately after Batman
zero year now I will explain that here
in a second but I do want to fin finish
this little bit of a of a train that's
going on this conversation with Gordon
and all that kind of stuff because all
it really shows is the nature of
Commissioner Gordon in relation to the
Gotham Police Department as you guys can
probably imagine cops in Gotham City are
pretty corrupt and in fact there's one
guy that he's talking to named Manny
where he basically says like you're a
crooked cop right like you have some
really really fancy stuff which is way
more than a police officer could afford
on their salary in this city of course a
fight kind of breaks out between the two
of them and as Manny ising by the
commissioner's office he comes out and
the two of them basically agree they
need to do something about Jim Gordon
now a lot of that goes into like the
early story specifically New 52
Detective Comics which focus on
Commissioner Gordon at least for the
first few issues or so and really
highlighted the fact that he was a good
guy in a city full of corrupt cops so of
course they wanted to Snuff him out and
get rid of him so that he doesn't really
rock the boat and bring the whole like
corruption racket just crashing down
right now to the discussion about Batman
zero years so one of the things to know
is that when DC rebooted in 2011 with
the new 52 the whole idea was to
basically start from zero with Batman
they kind of did kind of didn't but
Batman zero year was the story of how
Batman became Batman right the death of
his family and the whole nine yards the
kicker about all this is that we were
introduced to a villain called the Red
Hood now this was built on an old Story
by guy named Alan Moore called The
Killing Joke which was at one point the
definitive story of The Joker which is
to say he was a guy who quit his job to
become a full-time comedian he failed he
had a wife and unborn child to support
he was caught up in a criminal racket
basically he was in the wrong place at
the wrong time a fight broke out between
him and Batman he fell into the ace
chemical vat and came out as the Joker
and the rest is history that was the
origin of his character for decades
right decades and decades going up until
zeroy year and when zero year happened
it was really just like Joker was an
unnamed guy he was just a dude with a
red hood on his head and that was it he
let a whole like criminal organization
and eventually they tried to like
destroy the city of Gotham and all kinds
of crazy stuff the point is like a fight
breaks out between him and Batman and
just like in the old Killing Joke story
he falls into the ace chemical vat and
is believed to be dead he ends up coming
out and this takes place immediately
after that right so this is kind of the
answer to the question what happened
between the time that he fell into Ace
chemical and the time that he like
fullon becomes the Joker that everybody
knows and loves right hence the
retelling of his origin here and so what
you do is you pick up with him in a bar
right where he's basically just kind of
picking a fight now the inner monologue
that he's experiencing basically the
kind of speech that's in uh purple
bubbles whatever you want to call it
that is like his Human Side his normal
side then there's like the person he's
becoming going insane basically being
broken mentally different things like
that kind of tying into the old uh
montra from The Killing Joke all it
takes is one bad day that sort of thing
and so it's trying to bring him down and
keep him from doing just like crazy
things while he's literally just going
off the rails and so that's why the
inner monologue that he has is telling
him to like stop talking and goating on
these bikers in this bar and to just
like chill and calm down and relax
because all it's going to do is create
problems but the Joker himself eggs
these guys on right like they're talking
about how like you know some guy was
giving him a hard time and he was going
to punch him out and the guy was going
to wake up on the floor and the Joker's
like actually he would have been fine
right because all you do talk you are
all talk and no action right that kind
of thing just goating these guys on and
on and on and so of course as this fight
breaks out between these guys and
they're just hauling off and they're
punching the Joker and whatnot that as
they're stomping him in a moment of
distraction when somebody's like hey
he's had enough that you end up having
like the Joker grab this bottle smash it
on the side of the countertop and then
just like slash one of these guys
throats with it right and then when that
happens this dude stops him only for us
to find out that it's Brian specifically
number 22 now the reason why this is
important is because during the New 52
and in zero year when you had the Red
Hood gang nobody used real names they
were all given numbers the reason why is
because if no one knew anybody else's
name then nobody had the upper hand on
anybody else nobody could get caught so
that's where if you go back and you
watch um The Dark Knight with Heath
Ledger's Joker and they're doing the
whole bank heist and they all play
different roles but no one really knows
what each person's role is supposed to
be right it's just I do this and then
that's that it's really predicated on
this right just give everybody a kind of
compartmentalized role and then go
forward from there give people numbers
don't give them names and it all plays
out in a way that works and it did it
actually worked fantastically well until
Batman showed up and he was able to
start deducing stuff but more so than
that you end up having this guy who's
just kind of watching The Joker right
like he's watching it all unfold he will
become important as time goes on
specifically once we get towards the end
of the story but in the midst of all
this chaos and all this pandemonium a
guy another dude right this white guy
who saw everything unfold basically
makes a phone call and we end up finding
out the person that he's calling is
number two the second in command of the
Joker's old red hood gang because what
they realize is that now he's back he
was not the Joker at the time that he
led the gang he was just a dude but like
now the leader is basically back and the
reality here is that it challenges
number two's role for leadership and so
his idea is we got to take this guy out
like we literally got to kill this guy
not only that they've actually been
changing up their names and seemingly
operating in different capacities we
don't necessarily know how far it goes
and it really kind of requires us to
sort of dive into really more halfhazard
guessing and hearsay than anything else
but it's one of these things where they
basically changed their name from the
Red Hood game to like the black hood
gang right like that's it right they
literally change what their hoods look
like but there is going to be an
instance where Batman's talking to
detective Gordon and he's talking about
how like it's the black hoods now it was
the gry hoods before so on and so forth
and so seemingly these guys just may be
changing their whole stick like every
single week which is actually pretty
smart because it may either be multiple
games operating or simply just one it's
really kind of cool and a really smart
way to throw off the cops but of course
we know it really won't do a whole lot
of good for Batman more so than that one
of these guys or some of these guys end
up orchestrating a heist B man basically
shows up and then of course deals with
these guys you know like they're busted
and they're basically strung up and he
beats them all up and that kind of thing
the stuff the Batman does right you know
it's it's just Batman stuff but Jim
Gordon shows up and the two of them kind
of start talking right and that's when
you get this really interesting
conversation right where Gordon
basically says I think that's it for the
black hood gang and then he says maybe
but there were red masks last week and
the gray ghosts the week before copycats
and distractions the Red Hood gang is
still out there they need to be our
Focus so that's where things were a
little murky right is it just really
copycats or is it potentially that the
Red Hood gang is just changing their
look and their appearance in order to
look like they're a different gang and
to throw everybody off their track we
don't necessarily know and I don't
really think that was a question that
was answered during everything that was
going on but one of the other things
that goes on here is that Jim Gordon
goes as far as to say great we're
battling copycat gangs we just recovered
from The Riddler and now we have to
possibly worry about some mildly
corroded genius gang leader why can't
these guys just go away and stay away
now that's kind of coming off the heels
of the bit of the conversation they had
where Batman considers the possibility
that the Joker is actually alive or at
least as he knows him at this point the
leader of the Red Hood gang because all
Batman knows is that he fell into a Ved
Ace chemical he has no idea what
happened after that but to Jim Gordon's
response and his statement about the
Riddler once you got towards the end of
Batman zero year going into like Secret
City and that kind of stuff The Riddler
launched this campaign to literally take
over Gotham and in fact he did if my
memory serves me correctly and if I'm
wrong feel free to correct me but if my
memory serves me the Riddler took over
the city of Gotham and then just like
started going through and shutting
everything down the only way to free
Gotham right life being able to go back
to normal was to like solve a series of
riddles it was really cool it was
actually one of the coolest stories that
you ever had with the Riddler itself but
in effect yeah he took over Gotham City
locked the whole place down I want to
say he flooded the City but I can't
remember if it was that story or the war
of jokes and riddles where the Joker and
The Riddler went to war with each other
like all these are stories that we've
covered while you'll find a link to
these in the Batman playlist at the end
of the video all this stuff is covered
there but still like I can't remember
off top of my head right exactly which
one of those it was the fact remains
like the Riddler attacked the city of
Gotham and almost won that's kind of the
reference here and so what is up going
on is that at this point in time the
Joker has not fully become the Joker yet
which is to say the guy who's obsessed
with Batman who's always always trying
to get Batman's attention and that kind
of stuff that's the reason why as he's
standing outside of a pizza place with
Brian the real name of the guy you know
number 22 that as they're standing
outside this place he sees Batman soup
overhead now Batman doesn't know that
this is the guy he's hunting for or
anything like that just doesn't really
even notice him but as soon as that
happens he takes off running he
immediately books it and he ends up
getting out to basically the Gotham
Reservoir right over by the old Ace
chemical lab and once he's there you get
the kind of I onic scene it's the one
that so many of you guys have probably
seen but you didn't know the context of
if you never read the killing joke but
it's the one where like the Joker is
just like he's got his hands and his
hair and he's looking down at the water
and he sees his reflection as like a
pale face and he's like going insane
with the Haas in the background in this
instance it's a little bit different
that instead what you end up seeing here
is the Joker's reflection of his normal
self of course it's symbolic but it's
him looking at his normal self and
symbolically he strangles that version
of his normal self in a effect he's
killing off what little bit of humanity
remained inside of him after everything
in Ace chemical and he even says like
you don't understand I'm chaos and just
kind of laughs to himself but this
person comes out of nowhere and says
chaos that fears isn't really chaos at
all right chaos is in and of itself
Fearless right and this guy says I've
been following you for months and I'm
impressed I don't impress easily and
when Joker asks who you are he says I'm
The Man Who can teach you how to harness
your mind and to never feel fear again
to be the greatest Force this world has
ever know and when Joker ask a question
like what makes you think you're
qualified to do that he says because I'm
the smartest man in the world and I
trained Batman right so to the ending of
this there is a side story that goes on
here we don't know exactly when it takes
place at least I don't know exactly when
it takes place because last we left in
the Batman com iics like this whole
story this origin is being told to
Batman by the Joker in a prison cell
right so it's that's really really it
but this whole secondary story centers
on the idea that like the Joker has been
captured and Batman gives this kind of
monologue right so again this is not
tied into what we just talked about this
is something separate and he says we
couldn't solve the Joker so we locked
him away in Arkham hooked up to a
machine it was Barbara's idea after she
became commissioner so seemingly this
takes place long into the future right
like at some distant point in the future
and he says where in his mind he was
still going still fighting still trying
to one up me more Humane than that
monster deserved except I made sure even
in his wildest imagination that I always
won but an Arkham doctor was too tempted
he wanted to study the most malevolent
and Brilliant mind to ever exist and so
of course the Joker basically escaped
killed the doctor and left a note that
said I'll see you soon and so following
that we pick up with Batman where he
says the Red Hood whether it's just one
or more he's calling me to where it all
started I don't have any choice and he
knows it right the Joker makes this
comment where he says you always follow
me like a love sick puppy condemn me to
dreams and you'll soon find yourself
there in darkness and so Batman just
kind of says to himself it was the last
thing he said to me and he was right and
now the whole situation is nightmare of
Darkness somewhere in the city Duke is
infected and his powers are absorbing
all the light plunging Gotham into
Eternal Night they're all gone I'm alone
so alone everyone's infected an audible
virus spread by laughter and now the
world is the Joker right literally this
ends with this Revelation that the Joker
virus is like a zombie virus everybody
in the world every every single human
being is now the Joker which I got to be
honest with you guys man I am liking and
enjoying this new retelling of the
Joker's origin this is the story I want
to see man this is the one that I want
to
read but with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end if
you need to get caught up on all the
Batman stuff that we've talked about
make sure you click this link to the
playlist and I will catch you all later
peace